[Music]
can you tell me how to find the area of
this regular polygon
let me give you a hint by drawing these
dotted lines
did it click the area of this polygon
can be looked at as the sum of the areas
of these triangles
the area of this regular polygon will be
the sum of the areas
of these eight triangles similarly
we could find the areas of most of the
regions bounded by straight lines
we simply have to decompose the areas
into triangles and rectangles
and our job is done but what about the
areas of regions
bounded by curved lines we can't fit the
triangles and the rectangles there right
as we mentioned earlier this is where
calculus comes into the picture
in this video we will see a general
process called
integration to calculate the area of any
region
no matter what its shape is the beauty
here
is that this process is also based on
the idea of limits
something that we're now confident about
in ancient times people knew how to deal
with regions bounded by straight lines
but finding the area of even a simple
curved shape
like a circle posed a problem
in one of our previous videos we saw
that the greek mathematicians
had found some headway on it do you
remember the idea that was used here
if the circle is placed between two
squares like this
we get a rough estimate of the area of
the circle
it'll be between the areas of the two
squares
and as we consider regular polygons with
even greater number of sides
our approximations will get better
eventually
the area of the polygons will approach
the area of the circle
this method of approximation is called
the method of exhaustion
let's have a look at another major
achievement of the greeks
in finding such areas look at this curve
you may have seen or learned about this
type of curve
do you know what it's called it's called
parabola
let's say we have a horizontal straight
line like this
and this point below it now if we
consider points
such that their distance from this line
and this point is the same
we get a parabola so the distance of
all the points from the parabola to this
straight line
will be the same as their respective
distance from this point
remember seeing a similar curve in our
previous videos
the stone thrown by nora into the sea
follows a parabolic path
actually whenever we throw something up
the object always comes down
following a parabolic path
unless it's straight up and down
a greek mathematician named archimedes
was successful in finding the area of
the region
between a parabola and a chord like this
he did it by the method of exhaustion
in the case of circles we had seen that
to exhaust the
area of the circle regular polygons were
used
but notice that the regular polygons
will not work here
can you think of other shapes that we
can use here
archimedes realized that triangles would
work
here how and why
first he chose a point c on the curve
such that
the tangent line at this point is
parallel to this chord
now look at this triangle let's say the
area of this triangle is alpha
then it turns out that the area of this
region is equal to four
over three times the area of this
triangle which is alpha
how if we look at these two regions
we can draw two more triangles like this
and it turns out by geometry that the
sum of the areas of these two triangles
is one-fourth of the area of triangle
abc
so now the area of this region will be
equal to
alpha plus one-fourth of alpha plus the
area of this remaining region
did you understand the idea here
if we keep drawing triangles further and
further
we will eventually cover the whole
region
we get that the sum of the areas of the
triangles added in each next step
is equal to one-fourth of the sum of the
areas of triangles
in the previous step so we get infinite
terms like this
and it turns out that their sum
approaches 4 over 3
times alpha note that i said
approaches here as we saw previously
we cannot add infinite terms manually
as we keep adding the terms we can only
find whether the sum
approaches a number or not so we get the
area bounded by this curved line and
this chord
to be 4 over 3 times the area of this
triangle
note that this is the point at which the
tangent is parallel to this chord
this result proved by archimedes is
called the quadrature
of parabola but did you notice a problem
here
to find the area bounded by different
kinds of curved lines
each time we have to find out which
shapes will exhaust the given area
if we have area bounded by curved lines
like this
how will we find the area then we need
to develop a general method to find the
area
of any region it turns out that the
answer to our problems
is rectangles in the next part
we will see the general method used to
find the area
of any region
let's consider this area it's bounded by
this curve
these two lines parallel to the y-axis
and the x-axis
we want to find the area under this
curve
but you may ask why we will see in our
upcoming videos
that most of our problems related to
finding areas and volumes
can be reduced to this problem for
example
let's say we want to find the volume and
the area of this solid
which is an elongated sphere now let's
cut the solid like this
and look at its cross section
if we know how to find the area under
this curve and above the x-axis
then our job is done we can see that
rotating this area by 360 degrees
will give us the volume of the solid
so this area was enough to find the
volume of the solid
also once we understand the method of
integration
we will see that it can be applied to
find the length of a curve
so if we know the length of this curve
rotating it by 360 degrees
will give us the surface area of the
solid
we will understand it in detail in our
upcoming videos
for now let's get back to our problem of
finding the area
under this curve we know that according
to these coordinate
axes a curve can be looked at as being
made up of the different points
each point on the curve is specified by
its
x-coordinate and y-coordinate
now tell me which points on this curve
will have the minimum
and the maximum value for their y
coordinate
these will be the two extreme points of
the curve a b
let's say the minimum y value is alpha
and the maximum y value
is beta now by taking these two points
we draw two rectangles like this
for better understanding let's draw
these rectangles
in two separate figures so we see
that the area under this curve will be
greater than the area of this rectangle
the area of this rectangle will be alpha
times this length
and this length is d minus c hence the
area of the rectangle
will be alpha times d minus c
and it can be seen that the area under
this curve
will be less than the area of this
rectangle which is beta times
d minus c so let's denote the area under
this curve by
a and we denote the area of this
rectangle
as s1 with a dash below it
this dash below tells us that the area
of this rectangle
is less than a similarly
we denote the area of this rectangle
also with
s1 but with a dash above it
now focus on the figure on the left we
divide this interval
into two equal parts and draw two
rectangles like this
now compared to the previous case we get
a better estimate of the area
let's denote the sum of the areas of
these rectangles
by s2 dash we can see that it will be
greater than
s1 dash but less than a similarly
if we divide this interval into more
parts
let's say n parts then we will get an
even better estimate
these rectangles are drawn by taking the
minimum value of y
in each part so we can see that as we
divide this interval even further
we will get closer and closer to the
area a
in a similar manner in the figure on the
right
we divide the interval into n parts and
draw these rectangles
note that these rectangles are drawn by
taking the maximum y
value not the minimum so the sum of the
areas of these rectangles
s n dash will be less than s 1 dash
but greater than a now
as we keep dividing this interval
further and find the sum of areas of
such rectangles
we will get closer to the area a
this is the general approach to find the
area
it's called integration integrating
is nothing but combining one thing with
another
to form a hole
using this method we can find area under
any curve
what we did here is that we first
divided this interval into small parts
then by taking the minimum and the
maximum y value in each part
we calculated two approximate areas
the first one will always be less than
the area under this curve
and is hence called the lower sum and
the second one will always be greater
than the area under this curve
and is hence called the upper sum
now as we divide this interval into
smaller and smaller parts
we see that the lower sum and the upper
sum approach a number
which is the area under this curve
this is the basic idea of integration
we will learn about it in detail in our
upcoming videos
so until now we have an idea of the
limit process
we saw how we can apply it to find the
instantaneous rate of change of any
quantity
the process of finding this rate is
called differentiation
in this video we saw how it is applied
to find the area under a curve
and this process is called integration
in the next video we will look at one of
the most important ideas of mathematics
called
functions we can understand the true
essence of all these ideas once we
understand the concept of functions
we will also see in our upcoming videos
that in a way
differentiation and integration are
opposite processes
to stay updated subscribe to our youtube
channel
by clicking on this somewhat of an
illuminati sign